dans les bras de qui vous sentez-vous le
mieux
les bras de Morphée
pour montrer en fait que vous avez bon
fond carisse un interview bisounours
[Musique]
alors
la dernière fois vous avez pleuré
je crois la première fois
à quel âge je vais vous faire votre
corps à une jeune fille kaaris
c'était très tôt très tôt 13 ans
vous avez vu Belle et Sébastien
il est beau le chien pour vous c'est
quoi la soirée idéale à deux
à deux dans une voiture avec un gros
joint
quelle est la chose la plus romantique
que vous ayez faite dans votre vie
je vous fais des fleurs à ma mère ah
très bien
il aime sa mère
vraiment vous entendez mieux avec les
gens de quel signe
astrologique
je crois pas ça il y a rien à faire vous
aimez les petits chatons sur Internet
pas sur internet mais en vrai j'aime
bien les petits chats
alors
vous l'appellerez comment votre premier
bébé
sous les mains peut-être dans les bras
de qui vous sentez-vous le mieux
pudique j'ai quelque chose à dire à
votre maman là
je vais venir l'avoir après vous allez
souvent bien sûr il faut tous les jours
super important
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu